what are the chances that repeated
spaced out below threshold exposure to
cope at 19 we'll end up conferring
immunity similar to diluted virus after
passages greetings from Peru LRU Cohen
spaced out that's what I want I don't
know what after pathogen we're first so
I know what the question means I wasn't
quite sure what the analogy for to
passage a fascinating is the laboratory
technique oh yeah so the question is
asking if you didn't come down with Cove
at 19 but you were exposed repeatedly to
Stars Cove - would that exposure trigger
immunity your immune system seeing
fragments basically what it's arguing is
like a vaccine well we have there is
some evidence and with covin 19 it's so
hard to know what that we think is true
is true there's been so much bad data
and so much bad analysis of the data
that are there but I have seen evidence
that looks compelling to me from what I
can judge of of the data that there's
actually been some background immunity
to coronavirus and populations that were
imagined to be naive to it suggesting
that exposure potentially to other
coronaviruses might be conferring some
immunity and so if that's true I think
it possible that you might end up with
some low-level
immunity to the novel coronavirus with
this sort of background low level of
media it's not exactly the same yeah
you're talking about you're talking
about two different things but but that
first result that I that I just
mentioned is incredibly hopeful the idea
that exposure to some of the other
rotating you know out there corona
viruses can confer some background
immunity for the novel coronavirus
is exciting it's actually one of the few
really rays of hope and this whole
pandemic yep although I have the
darkness that will absorb that ray of
hope as always a paper recently emerged
that suggested that even people who had
been infected I think I'm understanding
it correctly I only briefly looked at it
but even people who had been infected by
SARS Cove to
didn't necessarily cero convert and
therefore we're testing negative on
these antibody test which also implies a
likely failure of immunity going forward
I think that's correct yeah
now you showed me I think you just
showed me the abstract but the idea
would be that the T cells kicked in
enough to allow the person who had been
sick to get better but then no memory
cells were generated such that you might
have had immunity for a week or two I'm
just making those numbers up but after
being sick with Kovan 19 but if you
didn't zero convert then you had no
immunity you know within a month after
being sick this is just terrifying
there's a lot of speculation here one
likely would be the T cells that did the
work which would then fail to create the
B cells that would create memory cells
that would give you lasting immunity we
don't know what any of the mechanisms
are frankly we don't even know that this
result is true you know you wouldn't
really want to see this result
replicated but if this result is true it
does suggest a there may be a more
surahs curve to circulating out there
than we know because it's evading our
tests better than we think and B that
the idea that if you had it your immune
might not be true in this case which
would be really bad yep absolutely
thanks for the darkness man you're
welcome
[Music]